die sie doch mal
Video heute
[Musik]
tododeku
ist ja schön wärs machen wir jetzt wohl
dieser wunderschöne Schleife hierauf
erstmal zum Preis Preis Preis Preis
Preis Preis wieder ganz kleiner zum
Thema Kreativität und er ist in
Kooperation mit Frau Hölle und Friends 4
Künstlerin mit verschiedenen Stilen und
Techniken 24 Projekte ein kreativ guide
mit Anleitung Zusatzmaterial und 45
Stabilo Produkte für eine kreative
Adventszeit finde ich gar nicht also
finde ich richtig gut der Preis liegt
bei 78,95 € das ist ein Stabilo Preis
[Musik]
okay ich wollte sofort mitmachen aber
wahrscheinlich
[Musik]
aha alles klar also
erstens hat man so eine Mappe und hier
sind die richtigen Türchen ich habe
jetzt keine Anleitung vorher gesehen
deswegen weiß ich gerade nicht ob ich
vorher die Mappe aufmachen soll oder was
das
zuallererst gibt's so ein Kalender für
2022 hoffentlich wird es ja besser so
schön
Handlettering mal die Anleitung ich
denke mal das ist Benutzung des
Kalenders
zum Briefumschläge und so drin und
Papiere und sehr
hochwertig das Design ist schön und er
ist aus Papier also alles richtig
gemacht und jetzt packen wir mal das
Beste und
natürlich beginnen wir mit
geändert
habt ihr wahrscheinlich gerade gesehen
und
max
[Musik]
[Applaus]
Berlin fräsvorlage nimm den beiden und
übertrage ich Vorlage hier ist meine
Kreativität gefragt okay also wir halten
fest für den 1 ist eine simple
Handlettering Aufgabe mit Vorlage da
braucht man nicht viel selber denken und
soll das an einfach nachmalen ich werde
versuchen auch vom Preis lohnt aber ich
werde ziemlich jeden Stück gleich nach
googeln und gucken hierfür nochmals 2 €
ja das machen wir später
befindet sich der Stabilo
Filzstifte
[Musik]
eine braune Beschichtung haben aber man
soll diese erste Verpackungs Schicht von
einer Milchtüte abreißen abziehen und
dann zurechtschneiden mit dem weißen
acrylic Marker dekorieren und ein
Teelicht reinstellen ich habe ein
bisschen Angst bei Pappel und Teelicht
in der Kombination sollte aber glaube
ich nichts passieren bis ne nette Idee
muss man sagen damit macht man sich so
schöne Scandinavia Kaiser und Maja
stirbt in der Familie Nummer drei
keine Weihnachtszeit ohne einen goldenen
und silbernen Glitzer Stift oder
metallic pens in Gold und Silber müssen
zur Weihnachtszeit einfach sein ich
werde so gut ausgestattet sein und was
machen wir mit unseren golden
Silberstift Weihnachtskarten beschreiben
natürlich mit Naturmaterialien ist nicht
nur ein Trend sondern macht auch
riesigen Spaß ganz
einfache
Weihnachtskarten selber basteln
warum findet eine eigene Weihnachtskarte
basteln
[Musik]
[Gelächter]
da brauchen wir jetzt wieder den
Goldstift und den fein Stift
Klappkarte alles ist wieder vorgegeben
um diese Weihnachtskarte zu gestalten
leider muss ich sagen ich weiß nicht wie
ihr das findet aber das Design ja das
sagt dir aber ich meine es nicht
unbedingt
[Musik]
lala glaube ich hier geht's dann wieder
um Händler Thüringen üben und die
buntstiftfarben miteinander zu
verblenden also nicht einfach nur zurück
zu auszumalen sondern halt schöne
Übergänge zu schaffen Leute jetzt ist
Nikolaus also nicht jetzt aber für uns
ist jetzt Nikolaus und das ist klein
ein
persönlicher
Weihnachtsmann
wenn man ja schon aufgestanden hat an
sein Türchen aufgemacht und dann packt
er lieber Nikolaus auch nichts mehr rein
und hier ist natürlich wie in jedem
Türchen anscheinend auch
ich ja deswegen finde ich den so ein
bisschen kompliziert ist das hier auch
ja ab und zu dann was drin ist also wir
haben hier noch mal für die
Weihnachtskarte auch so Vorlagen für
falalalala Vorlage für unseren Strom ja
ich weiß auch nicht wie man das machen
soll
dann sieht man auch das was man alles
braucht man dass man eine Vorlage aus
dem Material hier braucht
ein
Stift auf
diesem
wann Tannenbaum aufstellen könnte
Fensterscheibe ein Tannenbaum malen und
dann ist es eure
Vorlage an die
Fensterscheiben
sieben Siege
für die Fensterscheibe
meine grüne mager für Fensterscheiben
benutzen sollte oder ob ihr vielleicht
Erfahrung damit gemacht habt und das
vielleicht nicht empfehlen danke dass
ihr so ein Video da müsst ihr einfach in
den Kommentaren mitmachen da es gibt ein
paar Fragen geklärt werden müssen weiß
ihr mögt es einfach nur zuschauen aber
heute ist ja auch mal diese Nummer acht
alles klar hier das ist die Vorlage für
unseren schwarzen acrylick pennen und
mit dieser Vorlage macht man so tolle
Anhänger für euer Geschenk dafür braucht
man Klarsichthüllen z.b. war nicht immer
noch so festhalten oder ihn benutzt halt
irgendeine Folie die ihr habt
transparente Geschenkanhänger ist eine
coole Idee wo das sogar Schneeflocken
reingepackt sehr sehr kreativ kommen wir
zu meiner absoluten Lieblingszahl ist
welches ist das ist die Nummer neun und
die Nummer 9 ist sehr lang und in der
sehr lange Nummer 9 ist
ich freue mich gerade sehr drüber was
macht man denn mit Textmarker zur
Weihnachtszeit
aber das ist die Größe von dem cake
Topper Augen Cupcake
[Musik]
war Mama Benz Kalender quasi eine
Vorlage für nicht allein gelassen eine
kleine Vorlagen aber so eine kreative
Blockade hat dann ist dieser wirklich
der größte Anreiz um was zu basteln
natürlich damit eröffnen die hier das
nächste Kunstprojekt
basteln
[Musik]
mit Papier
Weihnachten
Labels macht für die Weihnachtsgeschenke
Platzkarten kann man damit machen und
wir haben natürlich eine Vorlage class
ich eine Vorlage dann kannst du daraus
deine Weihnachtskarten basteln Ideen
wiederholen sich jetzt ein bisschen ich
wüsste aber selber nicht was man jetzt
noch alles so basteln könnte sollte
achso und man kann man kann diese
natürlich auf Pappe malen und auf alles
ne
wir haben die weihnachtliche Farben
Gold und Silber
Gold und grün
sie mal gerne mir und bei den ganzen
Weihnachtskarten gebe ich euch jetzt
eine kleine Challenge für Weihnachten
schreibt man jemanden den ihr vielleicht
an Weihnachten nicht sehen oder den die
Allgemeinen nicht aussehen könnte
schreib dir mal dieses Jahr noch eine
Karte wenn ihr das nicht eh schon
gemacht hat und dann haben wir
heute das große Los gezogen ist wieder
in
rosa-pink sehr weihnachtlich Weihnachten
benutzt eine farbenfrohe
Weihnachtsanhänger also für euren
Tannenbaum und da benutzt ihr mal wieder
Pappe Kartonage dickeres Kraftpapier
also das was quasi auch mit dem
Adventskalender mitgekommen ist gestern
gesagt habe ich hier sieht das mit dem
pinken Tisch aus
kunstwissenschaftliche Analyse
Farbkombination
Stifte
Hardcore weihnachtliche Kombination
grün ein bordeauxrot und ein klassisches
grauen was für ein Schildchen Anhänger
Christbaumkugeln was machen wir jetzt
mit
dem weißen Körper sind natürlich diese
wasservermalbaren also Aquarellstifte
das ist natürlich
lernt man diese Weihnachtskarten
basteln tut mir leid
[Musik]
ist die Farbkombination von dem ganzen
Adventskalender nein ist die die ich auf
meinem Zimmer haben wollte also ich habe
sie nicht ganz hingekriegt aber so
ungefähr sollte es aussehen es gibt dir
diese Bilderrahmen die ein bisschen
dicker sind und dann hat man Tiefe im
Bilderrahmen und dann schreibt man auf
das Glas hohoho annimmt die Glasscheibe
von seinem Bilderrahmen und legt sich
hier um drauf und dann kann man die
Glasscheibe mit dieser Schablone quasi
malen und dann wahrscheinlich noch ein
Bild da drunter malen
steht hier drauf seid brave dieser
kleine Textmarker
Textmarker
kreative Projekte umsetzen und zwar
Kerzenhalter Flasche das ist natürlich
classic Upcycling Projekt mit einer
Glasflasche und macht sie hübsch und
packende Kerze rein soll man natürlich
auch noch Tannenzweigen machen klar und
natürlich bekommen wir hier auch und
natürlich bekommen in der Lage ist klar
hier ist noch fürs nächste Türchen Küche
Nummer 19 classic Gold und Silber
Buntstift ich muss dieses Jahr so ein
selbstgemachten Jahreskalender oder so
machen bei diesen ganzen das ist aber
das Problem Korken
Weinflasche hat noch Korken weil alle
Weinflaschen die ich in letzter Zeit
gekauft habe hatten immerhin
Schraubdeckel korkenwand früheren
Problem aber heute Sektflaschen
verkorken 1 Glühwein 2 Glühwein 3
Glühwein du hast noch gesucht er
mit diesem kleine Tannenbäume und du
kannst du natürlich diese Stifte
benutzen
und dran machen aber natürlich macht man
das selbst
gut dass dies nicht alle
Weihnachtsfarben haben weil dann kann
man sie auch übers Jahr weiterhin
benutzen ich wüsste jetzt keine Idee
wofür aber bestimmt gibt's Taxi Ostern
kommt ja auch da muss man wieder basteln
machen wir hier für ein tolles Projekt
und blauen Stift haben früher
Weihnachtskugeln Aldi Weihnachtskugeln
die euch eure Oma vererbt hat und ich
mal einfach tolle Tannenzweigen da drauf
toll toll supertoll Weihnachtskugeln aus
den Zwanzigern sind oder so super
perfekt dann
Weihnachtskugeln kann man natürlich auch
mit diesen acrylstifte Nummer 21
Nachsendeantrag lässt sich nicht so gut
formen also ein Drahtnetz sich zwar gut
vorm aber so eine perfekte Rundung damit
herzustellen schwierig ja ja ja dann
kann sie so machen wie man möchte dann
muss er nicht mal alles eins zu eins
kopieren Nummer
Filzstifte in lachsfarben nee in
1 pink Version und einem Flieder
onet das ist doch süß wenn ich das Haus
erzählt dann stelle ich es mir so groß
vor Vorlage so heißt es wird so
inzwischen haben sich vermutlich einige
Kartons angesammelt warum also nicht
etwas daraus bauen das sowohl als Deko
als Geschenk verpacken Kissenbezug hier
zu nehmen zu Onlineversand den ja alle
jetzt mittlerweile machen und ja ob sie
jetzt gut ist oder nicht ist mal
dahingestellt aber man hat viel Karton
und aus Karton was basteln ich glaube
dass in Zukunft bei jeder hat viele
Kartons zu Hause ist es sehr kleine
Vorlage das ist ein sehr kleines
Häuschen das ist eine schöne Alternative
zu allerdings möchte ich dieses Jahr
unbedingt wieder ich habe so lange keins
gemacht ich glaube ich habe nur einmal
in meinem Leben eins gebastelt also
Bilder
[Musik]
meine Damen und Herren es ist der 24 es
ist Heiligabend wann hat den Dezember
hinter sich gebracht man hat viel
Glühwein getrunken man hat gleich in der
4. Welle gesteckt und ganz alleine zu
Hause verbracht man weiß es noch nicht
ich bin kein Hellseher in und jetzt ist
der 24 und hoffentlich kann man mit
seiner Familie Zeit verbringen freut
sich drauf auf die Liebenden wann hat
eigentlich gar keine Zeit wird man hat
einen gar keine Zeit zum basteln aber
trotzdem nimmt man sich die Zeit und man
geht an seinen Adventskalender und
fortios 24 Türchen
und man bekommt zwei Textmarker mit be
happy und collect Moments bin ich
enttäuscht von welchem Projekt gibt es
denn zu diesen zwei Textmarken
Christbaumkugel ich mach doch keine
Christbaumkugel an dem Tag hätte
Tischkärtchen rein weil man für den
Weihnachtsabend fürs Essen Heiligabend
irgendwie eine schöne Idee bräuchte und
keine Christmas Kugel Weihnachten aber
damit sind die vier und endet
meine-arztrechnung EDV Video aus den 24
leeren Adventskalendertürchen den Korpus
und dann Mappe neu praktisch oder
dekorative
gestaltet Leute und dann kann man mit
denen Scheibchen die man daraus gemacht
hat kann man Schmuck herstellen ist eine
gute Idee und man kriegt sogar im
Onlineshop Gutschein weil man nach 300
stiften jetzt noch mal braucht also
diese beiden Zitate an den Seiten wie
kann man natürlich als Poster verwenden
sind sehr schöne Poster tatsächlich mag
die Farbkombination ich finde es ist
sehr süß und ja crate everyday
gute Aufbewahrung Adventskalender für
mich gut man kann ihn einerseits dann
zum Basteln benutzen oder ihn wieder
verwenden tolles Design kann man immer
wieder machen und
sich ja dann vielleicht was anderes
einpacken
die man bekommt alles super tolle
Weihnachtsfarben mit ein paar Ausnahmen
die aber jetzt nicht so schlimm sind
preislich das ist jetzt die
gutefrage.net was kostet so ein Stift
das interessiert mich natürlich auch wie
das jetzt hier kostet 6 € für 6 Stück
wir haben hier
eine Seite 4 € für die Textmarke
acrylmarker
wasservermalbare Stifte Pinsel Stift Pen
68 alle Farben 125 x 675 jetzt kommen
die normalen Filzstifte Fasermaler Pen
Stifte
Preise variieren auch man kriegt das in
dem einen Laden dann vielleicht zehn
Cent günstiger aber wir waren ja
ungefähr wissen was ich kriege
sTABILO Pen Stifte
666 dreimal die sechs die Zahl
15 x 4 Stifte 4 € 60,30 € für 2 metallic
Stifte jetzt haben wir hier einen ganz
besonderen diesen mit denen wir auf der
Scheibe dieser wood
Handvoll ich weiß nicht mehr was ihr
noch alles mitbekommen habt ich habe
lange nicht auf die Kamera geschaut bin
jetzt gerade bei dem letzten dem Stabilo
Sensor Euro am meisten haben sich diese
acrylstifte rausgehauen also die sind
Premium Ware hier drin also ich bin
jetzt bei einem Warenwert von ungefähr
75 € rausgekommen der Kalender hat
gekostet
78,95 € wir haben einen Warenwert von
ungefähr 75 € und das ist ja nicht alles
also ja da fehlen jetzt 3 € zum
Kaufpreis ist aber wirklich ein sehr
schön gemachter Adventskalender also da
steckt ja viel Arbeit dahinter dass sich
Leute so ein Konzept ausdenken und
Bastelideen mit reinschreiben und man
bekommt ja zusätzlich noch Blätter
Vorlagen dieses ganze Drumherum wie sagt
man so macht es mit dem Adventskalender
kein guten Stabilo Dielmann bekommt viel
mehr Produkte für den kleinen Preis aber
das was man bekommt ist wirklich sehr
herzlich sehr liebevoll bisschen und
manchmal dass man denkt ja gut die Idee
kommt jetzt wie schon zum dritten Mal
trat wurde jetzt hier nicht neu erfunden
mit den kreativen Ideen aber es ist eine
schöne Anregung also wenn ich jetzt
überlege dass ich zur Weihnachtszeit in
jeden Tag so ein kleines Bastelprojekt
hat es ist nett und das bringt bestimmt
ein auch gut drunter und ich kann mir
vorstellen warum dieser Welt Kalender so
gehyped ist und warum den so viele
lieben ich bin jetzt auf jeden Fall Fan
ich weiß noch nicht ob man wirklich
jeden Tag so ein Projekt anmachen würde
also ich glaube da liegt dann am Ende
auch viel rum und ja das mache ich dann
auch noch in das mache ich auch noch
aber ansonsten sehr schöner Kalender
reichlich ja muss man sich halt
überlegen weil 75EUR für den
Adventskalender oder 78 € das ist halt
viel wenn man das Geld hat dann ist das
nett es ist ja auch eher an Erwachsene
gerichtet bzw ist es an Erwachsene
gerichtet die haben dann doch er das
Geld als jetzt ein Teenager oder ein
Kind also das wäre jetzt auch glaube ich
von den Projekten her nicht so
kindgerecht deswegen ja finde ich sehr
gutes Design alles drum herum ich
verstehe warum der gehypt ist es ist
wirklich eine nette Idee und schreib mir
gerne was ihr dazu denkt und vielleicht
langjähriger Stabilo Adventskalender
Fanseite ist der vielleicht besser oder
schlechter als der im Vorjahr ihr könnt
mir eure Erfahrungen reinpacken Andi
vielleicht am Anfang noch viel besser
und sind über die Jahre schlechter
geworden ist es besser wenn wir uns das
nächste mal wieder ich weiß nicht warum
aber ich bin so müde geworden während
des Videos ist ist noch nicht zu spät
weil ich auch ein bisschen zu viel
geredet und